this line of code is the shellshock
exploit and I'm using it here to check
whether my system is vulnerable to the
shellshot bug which some would say is
even more damaging than heartbleed I'm
using the echo command to print out some
text and I'm passing this into the
shellshock exploit so that if the system
is vulnerable it will print out and
vulnerable to the screen and as we can
see on here it's printed out vulnerable
so this system is vulnerable so this
system now I'm logged into is on our
local network whereas this one is my
local laptop and has been perhaps so if
I execute the code on here it doesn't
print vulnerable because the machine
isn't vulnerable shellshock is a bug in
a program called bash now for those of
us who use unix-like systems such as BSD
OSX
Solaris and of course Linux sorry gönül
Enix will be very familiar with this
program it is what's called a shell now
unix-like systems are primarily command
line based in similar to those if you
remember DOS on pcs before that and the
command prompt that you get in Windows
so bash itself is a gue new
reimplementation of a shell that was
developed by Steven born in the late 70s
he developed and it's documented in this
technical report from Bell systems the
bourne shell is named after himself
which was an improvement on the original
thompson shell one of the big benefits
of the shells in unix as well as
enabling you to interpret commands for
you type in you can write what are
called
shell scripts now a shell script is just
a series of commands that are placed
into a text file that you can then
execute to do useful things so this is a
script I wrote to check my mail every
time I logged in all it is is a series
of standard unix commands that are
executed in order and it does some
postally on the output of these commands
to tell me either
that I have known you mail or how many
messages I have I wrote the script when
I was an undergraduate here and it's
been running on the system's
ever since now this script is quite
useful because it shows us some of the
more advanced features of bash one of
the examples of this is that we can set
variables in bash one of the other
things we can do is create functions and
just like a function in a programming
language is a series of things you can
execute and call several times bash
scripts allow us to define functions
that we can call several times within
our bash script
do something useful you can also pass
variables down from one program into any
program that it calls these are referred
to as environment variables so this
example we've got the term variable
which is set to say this is a 16 color X
term any program can look at that and
see what type of terminal it's on and
then generate the correct codes to say
set the color to be red if it's possible
you can also create functions that can
then be passed in to bash on the
environment and it's this ability to
create environment functions as they're
called this is being exploited in the
shell shock exploit so for instance we
could create a function called hello and
we put in the opening and closing
bracket a curly brace now we can put in
the commands that we want to execute in
this case echo hello computer file and
if we then pass that into a new instance
of bash when we type hello
note the misspelling has deliberate it
executes those like commands and in this
case prints out hello computer file what
people realize with the shell shock book
is that after that definition of the
function if you put a semicolon after
this function definition which to bash
means those more commands to come and
then put in some extra commands say like
echo hello Brady then when we start this
Bash starts executing them because it's
no longer as part of the function it
just starts executing them it says hello
Brady even though I've never told bash
directly to do that now why is this an
export it's a bug but why is this X
politically I could have just typed echo
hello Brady at the keyboard and had
exactly the same effect the problem is
that shell scripts are very much uses
the glue on UNIX systems to stick
everything together so the environment
variables are passed around from process
to child process all the time and uh
normally normal things like what
terminal are you running on what's the
current user what's the current
directory if we set one up that contains
our malicious code eventually something
will run bash and as well as running the
code that's checking for our emails
because Bash is buggy it'll run this
extra bit of code of ours as well where
this becomes a real problem is when
environment variables are used to pass
things into systems that perhaps we
don't even have access to so a common
example of this
be a web server the other thing we want
to be careful is that bash is used on
lots of systems for example nas boxes
smartphones and so on so they all should
be patched as well to make sure that
there's no lurking exploits on systems
you perhaps didn't think about so yeah
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computer valve video if
you go to audible.com slash
computerphile you'll find loads of books
to choose from and there's a chance to
try one out for free today I'd like to
recommend how we got to now by Steven
Johnson it looks at some of the things
we've come to rely on in modern life
like spectacles and fridges and Wi-Fi
for instance hedy lamarr the movie star
had a hand in the underlying technology
that drives Wi-Fi and bluetooth who knew
so check out how we got to now go over
to audible.com slash computerphile
try a book out for free thanks once
again to them for sponsoring this video
so it's a bit like panning for gold we
stick our metaphorical sieve into the
mud we pull out things and we're shaking
it around occasionally or we pull out is
much just random data we can't decipher
but occasionally pull out and we start
together and we get those gold nuggets
so we're interested it